I've always been pretty good making a
to-do list you know I think a lot about
being at the end is being a self-starter
and typically I'm out there in the world
and interacting with people in real life
so I knew that can happen if I'm
practicing self-isolation by is there
another way to feel connected with
people your guitar lessons have been
such a cool thing what have been what's
the response been like we are a ton of
people watching for me it was just
something to do to keep busy but as we
started going I realized that it happens
really interesting conversations with
people all over the world we talked to a
fan in Germany who translated our song a
leather jacket into German we talked to
a woman who's quarantined in Italy right
now who's setting 11:11 first in Italian
and we've had special guests on the show
Mitch martyr in Toronto Maple Leafs yes
a virtual Joel Plaskett just really
interesting people so we kicked off this
planet for music class challenge with
the goal of raising $25,000 and we've
done it so huge thanks Argosy for puttin
the bill they've already donated I've
time to food banks can already and thank
you to everybody who participated in the
planning for music class challenge and
where we're gonna be going up so I keep
busy at home and we gotta keep thinking
about all the people that our clients do
an incredible work
[Music]
bandying attaboy it's been great you
know we've had a chance to beam them in
videoconference out on the Instagram
live chats so Mike our guitarist will
show people how to do this solo in one
of our songs or Tony will show how to
play this keyboard part or tip will show
people have you warmed up for a gig so
it's been really fun to see them we've
been also been able to work on other our
talents creative projects from home like
we're sending around mixes we're working
on acoustic ideas so it's actually been
a fruitful time in that way for sure
yeah so I was just gonna ask you as far
as new music is going how is this all
affecting that creative process but we
are able to with technologies send along
a lot of ideas to each other and build
upon those so it's actually been yep
pretty pretty interesting for us to work
in this way and we're driving positive
and how did the fans been reacting to um
I mean obviously tour plans have to be
postponed or changed I mean number one
do you have any idea of when you think
you'll be getting back out on the road
and number two what's the fan reaction
been to to that idea that they might not
be able to see you for a while yeah
pretty understanding right now
everybody's life has been changed and
everybody has to show some patience and
more than anything this kind of
collective idea that we need to do
everything we can to serve the people
that are most vulnerable and the health
care workers and the frontline workers
beautiful part of this is that people in
a way of there's more compassionate than
ever so when it comes to our touring
we're just we're really leaning on the
public officials to tell us when we can
hit the road me and no one's going to be
a cowboy and go up there and say I'm
gonna do my own show we're just
literally waiting to know when we can
turn the lights back on and until then
we're just gonna keep losing on
everybody to go on
[Music]
watching stuff we're catching up on
anything yeah I gotta say Tiger kick is
the thing that I just watch
holy smokes I can't that's one of the
best documented have ever seen it's
insane what a sorry I'm so glad is drop
during this quarantine period because
it's really kept us all I need over
occupy on that yeah we're all saying see
how insane things could be right yeah